What's up?
>> Hello. Hello. Hello.
Um give me a second. I'm going to do one
last thing and just post it over on
general and then we'll be good good to
go.
>> Will you post it in my Discord, too? I'm
lazy.
>> AI that works today. Dynamic schemas.
Send now and then I'll post a great
thread. Boom. I hope that is the guest
invite link and not the other link. Let
me delete this real fast. Delete.
I think I sent the wrong link.
Uh people and then let me send
invite.
Yep. I definitely sent the wrong link.
Audience copy.
Um
>> Did you invite them all to be co-hosts?
>> Uh I did. I did. I went to
Um do you want to do you want to go post
in your the Human Layer Discord as well?
>> Um yeah. Did you update the link?
>> I did. Um
you should all see it.
All right. Um with that, uh welcome
everyone. Today we are going to do an
episode that I am very very excited to
go do, which is all about how to do
dynamic UIs.
And how do we build dynamic um
systems where we sometimes don't know
what the model is going to go do. So,
we'll give it a couple minutes and then
we'll start in um
we'll start pretty soon.
>> Amazing. We need to get some like filler
like uh background music for the for the
lobby vibes.
>> do. Um yeah. Let me put something up on
up.
Boom.
>> Get Suno to do like a techno Mortal
Kombat theme.
>> Uh dude, I
this is uh music is sadly not my domain.
So, we'll have to figure out how to get
that going for you actually because I I
have no idea how to pick the right songs
or anything.
>> Well, no. You just have AI generate it,
dude.
>> Oh, maybe. When we were making the
YouTube videos at first, um
uh for our team, my team I started
adding music everywhere and my team was
just like, "No. Stop."
>> No. No music.
>> Okay. we got some we got some MK fans.
Oh yeah, we could put on the Skyrim
loading scene. That would actually be uh
Someone was talking, I saw on Twitter
someone was posting like
uh
the uh Claude uh like while it's
thinking or waiting or whatever it is,
just showing the Skyrim loading loading
art while you're waiting for Opus to
load go take a long time to do whatever
it's doing.
I don't want to show this for like a
minute.
Uh 20 seconds.
I mean
>> Yeah, I think one of Also, what's
interesting this week is we didn't send
the Luma out this week uh because I was
slammed for reasons I will say later.
>> But I Bob has some fun news coming.
>> Yeah, but it it'll be interesting to see
how many people actually go with Luma.
It sounds like it's a
uh it sounds like it's definitely a
thing they'll have to do more regularly.
>> Amazing. All right, um we're it's 10:05.
Let's get started. This is AI that
works, the show where we teach you how
to take AI from demo and uh you know,
toy examples and build things that are
actually production grade that work in
the wild. I'm Dex, I'm the founder of a
company called Human Layer and we got
Vibhav here. I'll let him introduce
himself.
>> I'm the founder of a company that builds
Bambo.
>> And today, you want to tell people what
we're talking about today?
>> Yeah, um
I'm going to start off with just showing
a demo that I've shown many, many times
that many of you may have seen before.
But I I think one of the most important
things that becomes possible with LLMs
is something that I find uh personally
very interesting, which is
dynamic UIs. How do we deal with schemas
that are totally dynamic, runtime
defined, and we don't even know the data
that's coming in?
So, many of you have probably seen for
example, this uh invoice processor where
we ask a model to look at this PDF.
And when it looks at the PDF, it just
looks at it, comes up with a schema that
models this PDF. Um if we run that
schema through an LLM, we can even get a
really good response coming out of it in
a way that I think is way more helpful.
Then
>> this is actually generating dynamically,
like creating the React components based
on the structure of the data.
>> Well, the React component is actually
predefined. It's like a JSON. It's a way
to render an arbitrary JSON object. And
we just do a tabular view.
But the steps that it's doing just to
just to prove that it's not recorded. Um
let's cuz I think people don't always
uh they're like, "Oh, maybe it's a
recording." It's like here's like a
quick screenshot of my phone.
And
boom, there we have it. It should pull
out the information right there. Um and
it is And if I zoom in a little bit, it
should be a little bit easier to see.
You can easily see exactly what the
information has. It's 10:07. It's
Tuesday, September 30th. There's a
picture of a person standing on a beach.
And there's some stuff over here about
like notifications that seems to be kind
of made up.
>> Yeah, Joy Chef, I don't have that app.
Is that like a
>> Um so I've no idea where it's coming
from, but I'll have to check it out. But
the point is like the model is able to
go look at this and make some inferences
around what's happening. And this all of
this is happening through a two-step
process.
Um and we'll describe what that two-step
is really fast uh by swapping over to
the whiteboard. This step is really,
really simple.
One second. I'm going to
I'm going to go to Okay. Yeah, the step
is actually quite simple. All we do is
we take in some image that's defined by
uh the model.
And we ask the model, "Given this image,
I want you to uh
model
is
take image
and give me a schema." And we ask it to
model a schema back to us.
And this is literally a prompt that we
will write I'll say, "Hey, given this
image, give me a schema."
Then what we do
is we take that schema and we say,
"Given the image,
please take
image
and output
schema." And I'll put this as variables
so it's a little bit easier to see. And
that's literally all the system is.
You take the same image, you take the
same schema, and then in theory,
you should get out a filled out schema.
>> So that's like a big JSON object,
basically.
>> Of some type, exactly. And ideally the
type is defined over here. And I think
this
while this concept is really simple,
I think it's one of the most powerful
concepts that becomes possible in the
world of GenAI in a way that very, very,
very few things can do. Specifically, um
specifically when I go look at it,
this sort of concept, what it can do for
us,
is it can really and give me a second,
let me just like
put this out here so that we have
another screenshot to have. What it can
do for us is it can and I'll give you
the screenshot of well, the schema as
well that comes out of it.
>> Yeah, if you can if you can pull the
schema and also like can we get the JSON
object that is being used to render that
thing?
>> Um I don't know. Let me see if that
button works. No, it does not work so I
cannot give you that, sorry.
>> Can you get it from the Chrome console
or something or not?
>> Uh it's fine. Keep going.
>> Okay.
>> But I think the whole point is if you
can define the schema really well,
then you can actually have the model go
output this stuff for you. I think the
reason that this is such a foreign
concept is most people have never done
this in regular software, but if you've
ever built some sort of like if you've
ever built like, let's say, a form
builder or if you've ever built a um
or if you've ever built like a uh
templating engine of some kind, you've
done this. This is basically just meta
programming.
You're having the LM do some of the
program you're trying to have the LM do
the programming so you can program you
can run that program later.
>> It's like
list list for reader macros all over
again.
>> I am actually have no have no idea about
list so I can't actually
comment on that. But I think the premise
here is if you can go do something like
this
you can then take this to the next level
and say that
what you could do is give me the schema
I want to build
a third component here.
Which is
I can ask a different question which is
which is given the schema
give me a react component
to render it.
>> Wow.
>> take the thing as an input over here and
that actually can make this component
and now you can take this plus this and
now you have a pretty render you could
theoretically have a pretty rendered
view
of the schema as well that isn't like a
hard coded view like the one I'm showing
you right over here. So I think the
whole premise of meta programming here
just opens a world in general to a whole
new set of possibilities that were never
going to be possible for most
applications. We just saw Anthropic
release something like this
in their most recent application where
they said hey you can just press the
button
and if you press the button then um it
will work.
And you can actually go see
you can actually go see a custom UI for
their new application.
This is basically what they're roughly
what they're doing.
You take a schema you ask the model to
render the schema and now you have a
really pretty view of the schema.
And if you do this way you can build
dynamic interactions on top of it you
can build more data like data legibility
in general because rendering is just
going to be prettier than
this arbitrary JSON blob.
But, you can also do other things. Like,
you could give
a person a human loop step that says,
"When I'm doing the schema right over
here, before I do anything else,
I can just do a really quick human
review.
Where before I actually do anything with
the schema, I can do a quick little loop
to make sure that this thing is actually
good.
>> Okay, so that would be basically taking
the human feedback and like if we were
going to extend this out, you can just
get the schema
or you can take the schema, send it to a
human,
and then basically pipe that back into
the same prompt again with the human
feedback until it's basically approved.
>> Or just let the human edit it
themselves.
>> Okay.
>> Right? So, there's so much you can do
here that I think makes it really just
makes this whole domain of like dynamic
schema generation so fascinating.
I mean, Typeform, if you've ever seen
Typeform,
uh which is like basically a form
builder app,
makes so much money because of how
pretty they made making schemas.
That's all they did under the hood. They
I mean, they do obviously do a lot of
stuff and I'm oversimplifying.
But, one of the things that they
definitely did in the very, very
beginning is they made it stupid easy
to build a lot of um
to build a lot of schemas on the fly.
So, that what you can end up doing is
you can just have really pretty forms
without having to do any of the mockery
around it.
And I think with the world of LLMs, you
can now do this for any problem
all the time. Let's talk about a
First of all, I I'll talk about a little
bit more complexity we can add in a
second. But, what's your first thoughts,
Stacks?
>> Type- Typeform's a really interesting
example. I'm I'm curious what you're
going to use to demo this. But, I mean,
I I like the way this builds
incrementally of like, "Look, you can
just do the schema and then you can look
at that and you can do something with
it." And then you can say, "Cool, here's
the schema and the image. Give me the
JSON." And then you can write your own
react component to render it. Or you can
say like, "Okay, cool. Look at the
thing, get the schema, build a react
component for the schema, do the
extraction, and then do a custom
rendering." And what's nice about this
is these are all kind of well modeled as
individual parts of the workflow that
could be tested independently. You can
get the first part working and and
verify that on 5s or like actually like
spot checking or writing real tests. And
then you can slowly build up to
something really, really cool. think is
especially if you're newer to and doing
AI engineering and doing context
engineering, I think um is a really,
really valuable pattern to think about
when you're building, right? Like if you
showed me that webcam demo of like,
"Hey, here's here's my phone, build me a
dynamic table." I'm like, "I have no
idea how the heck to build that." So, I
like I like the way this is laid out. Um
what were you thinking about kind of
like as a demo use case today? Cuz
obviously we already have the
the extractor thing working. But like
what Have you Have you thought about
like what would be the best way to like
demonstrate this live?
>> Yeah, I have been. Um let me just put
this over here by the way, just so
people know what phone what photo we
used
>> Yeah, you can put that over my shitty
hand-drawn image of a sun and a cloud.
>> Um let's put it over here.
Uh maybe. I think I want to I want to
talk about a couple of things. I think
what I'm going to do is probably walk
through this actual code.
Um and just show people what this code
ends up looking like.
Uh firstly, like even the most basic
part of like how do you even go from
like ask the model to generate a schema?
What kinds of schemas work well? What
kinds of schemas work poorly?
Talk about how to do actual streaming
over here.
And like how how do I get it to stream?
Cuz that's a whole different problem.
Talk about what it takes to render the
schemas in different ways of doing that.
And then I think if we get to it, I'd
love to do the react component stuff as
well and show how to go do that.
>> Okay, awesome.
Even in the rendered UI, there's so much
capability that can go into this
of how to make this possible.
So, I'm going to try and take it step by
step and make sure that we're really
detailed in this walk-through cuz like
the fundamental building block of hey
model design me a schema and then what
can I do with the schema is super
powerful.
>> Uh there's a question real quick. What
do you mean What do you guys mean by
getting a schema from the image? It's
It's a good question um that we should
probably make sure is super clear before
we
>> this really fast. I'll use a different
example that we've been using uh that
I've been working on.
I'll I'll use um like over here I'll
just start an app. So, over here let's
say I have an app. I'm going to upload a
file.
I will upload a
file that's like um
mean.txt like this one.
Uh why not? Let's do some meta um meta
theming here.
And what I'm going to have the LLM to
do. Go ahead, Dex.
>> No, I was just going to say so when we
say generate a schema from the image,
it's not hey AI turn this image into
data or turn this into text. It's a
little more meta. It's saying, hey AI,
can you tell me if you were going to
extract data from this, what would the
schema for that be? And this is like a
really interesting flavor of of context
engineering where you're using AI to
generate something that goes into that a
downstream prompt. People have been
doing this for years. The original agent
was like use one LLM call to make a plan
and then use another LLM call to execute
it, right? This has been around since
2023 in the early days of ChatGPT. Um
this is a lot more kind of like
structured and and
you know, you're but
how do I say it? I don't know. Help me
out here.
>> Um Eugene has actually got a couple
questions. I'm going to let Eugene in uh
really fast.
Um hey Eugene. Come on in. What uh and
while while Eugene loads in I'll just
I'll just articulate what I think Dex
was saying.
>> Thanks, Dex.
>> It's exactly
It's
>> Oh, sorry, Eugene. Uh can you not screen
share really fast? I'm going to have to
turn this off.
>> Of course.
>> All right.
Uh, do you have a
I'm going to go back to screen sharing
the screen.
>> Yeah, let's let's let's let's double
down on kind of like how Yeah, what how
do you get a schema from an image? Um,
and yeah, what's what what makes this
more advanced than the, you know, make a
plan and then execute it is that we're
not passing something into the prompt
and
>> Of course. Of course. Um, I'll let you
guys finish. Sorry.
>> Okay, seems like there's a little lag.
>> I'll call him in a second. Let me I
think there's a I'm we're probably not
very good at this.
Um, I'll kick you out for a second. I'll
invite you maybe in a bit when we're uh
when we're back. Sorry, Dex. I don't
know how to get someone out of here. Um,
if you can do that.
>> All right, I'll leave.
We auto-generate
>> Sorry about that. Um,
but let me describe the schema thing
really fast.
So, in the schema thing what we did is
we asked the LM to say, "Hey, given this
image that I have over here,
define a schema." And the model said,
"Okay, well, here's the schema that I
have associated with this. Class dog,
there's a banana in there." So, I
modeled a banana. I'll model some socks.
I'll say that there's a background over
here. There's an image description of
some kind. And then the thing that I
want to give back. Because defining
schemas is not sufficient. Not only do I
have to define a schema, I also have to
tell you what about the schema do I want
back. I want an image description back.
So, there's basically a two-party
problem here when I generate schemas of
any kind. One, I have to model every
single schema. And then I also have to
give me the type of the thing I want
back.
So, in this case, I just asked the LM to
go and do that for me. And once it does
that, what I can do is I can just say,
"Okay, now given this image, run this
code and and uh return this type back to
me, image description," which is
described down here.
>> So, instead of the model having to think
about one, what data is interesting and
what shape should it have, and also what
are the values for that data, you're
kind of separating the work into two
separate tasks, basically.
>> Exactly. And now, when I go run this,
what I can do is can run this code that
I generated, and the model should in
theory uh it's always in theory because
it's AI.
Um but it should in theory print out
all the information I want right over
here. So, it actually printed out all
the stuff where it actually says
colors are pink, blue, and red.
Um for type
uh for the dog as well. I can print out
render the JSON view, I can render the
YAML view, I can render
a view that I defined as pretty.
That's just like nested objects.
>> I feel like I feel like there's a lot of
purple going on in your your your your
definition of pretty.
>> Honestly, I think you you tell any model
to generate code, it just says purple.
Uh
This actually isn't my choice.
Um I promise.
>> Um Javier would like to see the two I
mean this code is open source, right?
But can we quickly look at the prompts?
>> We'll walk through the code in a couple
seconds.
Cuz this code is fully open source. It's
going to be in the AI that works repo,
so you'll all have access to it as well.
Um but all this stuff is to say that
like once you have this, there's just a
couple kinks you have to do to iron out.
Like you have to figure out how to do
streaming. Turns out streaming is
actually kind of annoying with these
dynamic UIs.
But the next step you can do here, if
you go back to our whiteboard,
is you can really just go and I'll take
a screenshot. That's if you can take a
screenshot and post them back over here.
Uh I'll take the screenshots in a few
seconds.
>> You're just going to put it over there.
>> of what we're doing, is all we did is we
said, "Hey model, tell me the schema."
Um
and I guess there's technically one more
thing that we added with the schema,
which is not just a schema,
but schema plus return type.
And the reason the return type is
important because as you saw in the
previous example,
one of the things that we did here is we
did generate quite a few schemas.
Technically, there's many schemas here.
And we just have to know which of these
schemas we actually want to return as
the top level
>> Uh okay, so this is like when you're
doing a swagger and open API spec, you
have all your object definitions, but
then each endpoint has to specify, okay,
which one of those does this thing
return? So you need to tell, okay, which
of those things is actually the top
level?
>> Or you might just return an array as a
top level object, too, right? You might
say, I want to return an array.
And now the model's going to return an
array as your top level object.
>> With one with one item in it, but yeah,
okay, cool.
>> Yeah, exactly. But I think all of this
is really really highly dependent based
on the actual problem that you're
solving. So like that's why the return
type matters, because you can't just say
that, hey, I want to go generate a
schema, you also have to say what is a
return type. So but once you have solved
that problem, then you have a second
problem, which is now you just take that
schema and return type and you uh you
ask the model
uh return type to say, hey, give me that
same image that I took the image of that
I used to determine the schema, go
return the return type.
Now, there's a lot of layers of
complexity that you can do over here to
make this a lot better. Like for
example, you could say that you save
your schemas in a database. So instead
of actually asking a model to generate,
you're like, hey, if an image looks like
another image from before, return the
same schema that I have saved in my
database. Don't ask a model for a new
schema.
So that adds a little bit Go ahead.
>> I was going to say, um just quickly, do
you want to try to get Eugene on? I know
there's a little bit of a delay.
So we might want to do
>> I'll do that in a second.
>> Yeah, that's okay.
>> Uh Eugene, do you want to type out your
question and then we'll get you in
there? Cool. Uh thank you.
Um
So what you can do over here is you can
actually go and build a lot of like
stability in here, because one of the
risks with dynamic schemas is your stuff
is constantly changing. And if it's
constantly changing, that
is a superpower, but depending on the
use case, it can also be a super
weakness.
>> But you may want to bake these, right?
If you If you go process 100, you know,
car loan applications or whatever it is,
at a certain point, you want to be
extracting the same thing from every
every one of those, otherwise, you just
have a bunch of JSON in your database
rather than like structured columns.
>> Exactly. And like I think the beautiful
part about doing this stuff in such a
nice way is technically we're using a
model to solve this problem, but there's
nothing that says that this model,
"Please take this image and give me a
schema."
is actually a model problem.
That could be a thing that says, "Hey,
load these schemas from my database."
Uh and then give me the schema and then
ask the model to extract the schema from
that image.
And maybe we initially seed it with a
database with a schema generated by a
model, but really it's a human process
that goes and edits it along the way.
And all of these are really use case
specific, but the premise that we have a
schema that we save in our database that
we then load and like re-render stuff
with or extract data with
is like one of the most common use case
for LLMs, and I think most more people
should definitely be looking at it along
the way.
But with this, I want to get to some
code. Uh
Eugene, if you have your question, feel
free to type it out and then we can talk
about it in a second uh along the way.
But hopefully that gets everyone a
really good concept around what we're
going to be doing today. Cool. Let's do
it.
I'm going to pull up Cursor.
>> Let's write some dang code. I'm really
excited to see the uh the dynamic React
component thing.
>> I agree. I have been actually playing
around with that, so I hope I can make
it worthwhile of everyone's time.
>> Looks like Eugene just had something he
wanted to show off in a time-boxed
window.
>> Oh, let's do that at the end then,
Eugene. Um
well well well we'll get you on towards
the end during the extra time once we've
actually shown off all the code.
>> I think that's good.
Sorry for the false start, dude.
>> Yes, I have lots of those as well.
Um
Cool.
I'm just going to
screen share my code.
Share.
I'll assume. Can you folks see VS code?
Perfect. I'll try and make it pretty
big.
Um
and
I'm going to start off with just the
prompts to show what it is.
There's two prompts here. One is called
generate panel, one is called execute
panel. I'm going to start off with
generate panel. This is all about schema
generation. So, what I do over here is I
say that
I'm first going to define the function
signature of the thing that I'm looking
for.
Along the way, let me just make the chat
window correct size. Second.
Okay.
Um
Cool. And this function is just a thing
that says, I mean I'm this function will
either take in a string, it'll take in
an image, it'll take in an audio, or a
list of images.
And then it'll return a schema object
out of it.
A schema object is defined as an object
that has a couple of fields. It has the
interface code.
It has the return type and then like
some other code associated with this.
I'll talk about why I did other code in
a second. It was just a prompt
engineering hack.
Um and then I just do some prompt
engineering here telling it to just not
worry about escape characters because I
found out schema is better. So, I just
told it answer with backticks to prevent
escape characters and that worked
really well when I was generating code
for me.
>> Okay, so quickly question. Um
this is you're having it output YAML
code specifically. I've also seen
examples of this where you just output
like a JSON schema style thing as well,
right?
>> I have seen that, but I actually
specifically found that the reason that
outputting YAML code works a lot better
is
>> Well, there's less syntax, right? Or the
syntax is easier for models to write.
>> Yeah. So, uh
I'll just give a quick primer over here.
Um
Screen share on my screen. I can't
switch screen share very easily.
Hide.
Stop. Screen share again.
Hide. Uh I'm just going to share my
whole screen, so please don't um
steal any API keys.
Um
>> Yeah, we're no longer on Zoom. We're no
longer on uh AI that works circle of
trust. We're on open internet.
Hide your keys. Hide your wife.
>> Well, let me just look at JSON schema
for example. If I want the If I want
something to be represented as string
array, this thing is 23 tokens in JSON
schema. I can just output string array.
It's just way less tokens for the model
to say that it wants a string array for
some field. If it wants like If it wants
to say something is like um
like uh what's it called? If it wants to
modify it from like a string string
string and string to a like string array
and int array,
zero token change.
If you want to say something is
required,
this is just 73 tokens to say stuff is
required. Like same field, 23 tokens for
the same data model.
And it even snuck in some extra metadata
about like what this is in ISO format.
So, it's just that JSON schema is just
extremely verbose.
So, I have found historically that I get
way worse results when I use JSON schema
than when I just like have it output
code something that looks way more like
code along the way.
>> Okay.
Cool. What else what do let's what else
what other what other code prompts you
want to show?
>> Um so, cool. Uh and then I want to talk
about Well, I want to talk about the
actual prompt. So, what is the prompt?
Well, I learned it self-to-generate BAML
schema. I give it this context. I gave
it some background about BAML. I'll show
what that is in a second. And then I
just CTX that output format and then
say, "Here's the content." That's It's a
really really simple prompt.
Yeah, I should have some test cases
here, too.
Um
but I'll show what the BAML description
is. It's literally about like
How many lines of code is this? It's
like roughly around Oh, it doesn't tell
me.
It's like roughly around like 30 lines
of code or 40 lines of code that
describe 50?
60?
>> 60.
>> 60 lines of code that describe all of
BAML syntax. and like I just described
the very basics of like
here's a class, here's how you do
nesting, here's how you do enums, here's
how you do literals, etc. etc.
>> This is your cursor rules for BAML. If
you If you wanted If you wanted cursor
rules for writing BAML, this is probably
what should get injected into every AI
prompt and when you're coding, right?
>> Exactly. And then I said I said the most
important thing. It's pretty much like
TypeScript but with one difference,
there's no colon.
Uh that was a mistake on our end. We'll
fix that later, but um that's about all
we do.
And once we tell the model that, then we
just like try it out on a bunch of
prompts.
And the prompt that I tried out was just
like simple resume example.
I just go run this and
it pretty much dumps out the code really
really well.
>> So the input is just this text string of
your resume. Will you scroll up scroll
up and just show that one more time? Or
like yeah, make that visible. So it's
literally just a markdown of your
resume. And so it's looking at this and
it's saying, "Cool, if I was going to
turn this into a structured object, what
would the fields in that object be?" And
then that's the schema we have at the
bottom.
>> It's right here. So it's like person,
full name, email, experience, skills.
And that looks pretty reasonable given
this resume.
Um but what I've and position as a
company title and then is current, which
is kind of fascinating.
I like that it decides that it is
current in there.
But what I think what I found is like
the reason that I added other code or
and you'll notice that the LM actually
did a pretty good job of that takes in
like outputting the schemas correctly.
And then even over here is like, "Oh,
maybe I'll add some other code."
Is when I didn't have the other code
example,
it actually started putting like logic
in the code and started being like,
"This how I want to call it. This is
what I want to do with this schema." And
start doing a lot more than it needed to
along the way.
But once I started restricting it to
interface code, return type, and other
code, then if anytime it did dump out
stuff like other code, it just put in
other code. I didn't care.
>> I see. So, you're using the field names
to basically steer the model as to,
okay, put the interface and the types in
one place. And if you find the need to
say anything else, put it over here. I'm
just going to ignore it. But you give a
model a dumping ground for, like, hey, I
want to write an if if statement or a
while loop or something.
>> Exactly. Exactly. Cuz I found it was
pretty often.
>> Fascinating. That's a really cool topic
that I or like concept technique that I
don't think I've really heard about
before, which is like giving the model
other fields to dump the things that you
don't want to so that your key fields
that you're working with stay really
clean and concise.
>> Exactly. Like it worked really well for
this problem.
>> That's dope.
>> It was like a It was one of the key
things I had to do to make this UI to
make this actually work in a very
reliable way.
>> How How did you come to that guess?
Like, how many things did you try? Did
you I imagine you tried a lot of
prompting first. You're like, don't
output code. Don't output code. Just
output types. And it turned out this
worked better.
>> It turns out the model was dumb.
At that So, then I did a couple of
things. One, I renamed this to interface
code. But even when I did that, it did
the dumb thing and added more code
sometimes.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I was like, okay, well, I need
this to be really, really robust. Well,
let me just give it a dumping ground.
>> Okay.
>> And giving it a dumping ground made a
huge difference and
in like update.
>> And then
>> I did this uh
>> Yeah.
>> Then like the back end code is really
simple. It's just a fast API server.
Um and all the back end code does is
there's basically two API calls.
One is called uh generate YAML stream.
And I have different hooks for stream
versus non-stream, by the way, just FYI.
Um and then what I do is I just generate
the stream with the simple function.
This stream I just have a handle stream
function.
>> And that just streams it down to the UI.
>> It literally just streams it down to the
UI. It literally just And it there's
like some some stuff that I have to do
in the UI to tell if I'm like in the
middle of streaming or if I'm done
streaming or if an error happened along
the way.
So, I have to go build this out myself,
and that part is kind of annoying. I
thought about how to make this better
from a BAML's perspective, but that's a
different topic.
>> Okay, so you're using the structured
streaming from BAML, but in order to get
FastAPI to talk to your front end, you
still have to kind of take the like
output chunks from that so the UI knows
whether it's finished or not.
>> Exactly, and there's just no way around
that, sadly.
>> Okay, at least
>> for now. And then, what I do is I just I
have a two-data function that says,
"Hey, given this data I get, convert
it." And if you go look at how generate
stream works,
generate
>> It's funny, I think I cloned this
example like 4 or 5 months ago, and I
was like playing with it, and I remember
being confused by like, "Okay, why do we
need a bunch of custom streaming code?"
But that makes sense.
>> Yeah, exactly. It ends up being very
tricky. Well, then you just do
x.model.dump. So, I literally just send
the raw JSON up as a part of the
>> giving you back a Pydantic model, but
you really want to just like emit JSON
over the wire.
>> Exactly, cuz what does generate This
thing returns a We saw earlier what the
generate stream return. Uh generate
returns
>> You should put mode equals JSON there in
case you get datetimes in your in your
output dictionary.
>> Um you won't
because it's generating BAML code, which
has types.
Uh so, it's returning a class that's a
schema
>> Okay.
>> along the way. So, you have a schema
type, and then you just do
schema.to_json.
Um I should be dropping the other code
variable cuz I don't care about it, so
that's a separate thing, but uh this
seems to work pretty well for our use
case. Um cool. So, that's that's one
part of the system. So, that's how we
stream, that's how we get it up and
running, and then the front end side,
I'll show you how that page works end to
end as well. As I basically have like
three states over here. It's like I
would want to know if I'm executing
anything.
I want to know if I'm generating, and
then here's the generated code, and I
want to know if what the execution
result is.
And you go to is executing, let's just
look at how generate works when someone
clicks the generate thing.
You literally set is generating to true.
You say here's the current input and
then you just call you build a form
model that you have to. There's a lot of
boilerplate code I have to do to send
like files from the front end to back
end and stuff.
So like that's just like standard chat
GPT code to go render.
And then the other thing you have to do
is because if you want to stream you
have to build SSE events on your own is
I have to build a utility layer to
actually handle SSE events.
And like pass that back and forth
between my front end and back end.
>> This is all
>> go ahead.
>> Those types are type arguments but this
the the values into the fetch SSE like
type constructor for the generics end up
being types that were generated by the
BAML TypeScript compiler, right?
>> you Yeah, I'll show you where these come
from. So this code is being generated on
the fly from BAML
automatically for you thanks to
our generate file. So generate file says
all my BAML code should have generate
generate Python bindings and react
bindings automatically for me.
>> And you can guarantee type safety across
the client and the server cuz it's all
one source of truth that's generating
both sides. Okay. Yeah, we've seen this
a lot with like using open API specs to
generate types but this is this is cool.
>> streaming the type is this type. So it
just makes like auto complete better.
That's like the only thing it really
does for our lives.
Um
and then you can actually set the gen
and then you get the response which is
the final type. So during streaming it
says
what this hook says is whenever you're
streaming you get SSE events on every
partial event run this run this
function. As soon as the thing is done
run this function and just set the final
response which is of schema type.
But this thing on partial is a partial's
partial type version of it. So like the
value during streaming along the way.
Um yeah, with this you basically have no
drift in your type system
along the way. And then once you have
this like rendering a string rendering
this string and this string in this
um UI component that I have. Rendering
all of Let me
pull out this onto a different window
really fast. I think.
Rendering rendering onto this window and
showing the actual BAML code versus the
return type. Well, now you guys know
where that's coming from. That is
literally just this variable generating
BAML, which is of schema type, which has
interface code and return type. And then
I just render those two fields.
>> I have a question. If you If you want to
do more, you can. I can I can I can hold
it for a second.
>> I'll talk about the execution logic in a
second cuz I think that code is also
very fascinating.
>> Cool. And there's Yeah, I think the
question about SQL for UI schema is um
we should tackle at the end. Um but
there's this question of like type and
workflow drift. Obviously, BAML lets you
use static types and kind of manage your
types really well for the pieces that
you're working with. But one of the
things that I know you say all the time
is types are amazing and like
there was a long time I think you
support like dynamic types in BAML a lot
better now. But there was a long time
where it was like an opinion of the
team. It was like you shouldn't have any
types. You shouldn't have any types in
your outputs because like any types suck
and the whole point of using this is
having like dynamic types. Or sorry,
having static types that you can catch
at compile time and make the dev flow
easier. This doing dynamic schemas, you
don't actually get any types. Or like
you kind of have to start working with
any types because the output of the
object is some just like nested JSON
thing that you get out. The schema
itself is just code. But maybe we can
talk about that when we get to the
execute side cuz the thing you're
rendering in the UI ends up being and
yeah, any object. There you go.
>> So, exactly. So, I actually have an any
object that I defined
uh that talks about this problem because
you're right, we can do anything.
Uh, and it is kind of bad that you can
do anything. So, like how do you deal
with this world where any type is now
suddenly valid?
Um, and this I think becomes really
relevant during execution, but I just
think you have to know that it is that
type. And once you know that it is that
type, then you can start writing code
around
around that world.
Um, so I'll talk about that in a second.
Let's talk about how execution works.
So, we talked about how streaming works.
Uh,
key part about generating code is about
having to build some sort of SSC bridge
between your front and your back end and
having some type safety guarantees so
that even when you're streaming partial
types,
that you know exactly what it is.
So, again, if you look at the fetch SSC
world, I actually handle
like my event data.partial versus event
data.final versus event data.error.
So, when I actually go send it from my
back end, I do I do exactly that. Um,
and I apologize if this is a little
repetitive, but I think it
this stuff is really easy to make small
mistakes on that makes it really hard to
go debug.
Same thing here. I'm just sending
partial, final, and error. And I just
catch that response up there. But, the
next step is actually about executing
demo code. So, now I have a type system
that I've defined, how do I actually
execute that?
>> So, you're taking the schema that was
created by the first call and then using
it to do the extraction during a
follow-up call.
>> Exactly. So, handle execute. Let's start
from the front end and work backwards
cuz we just sent our schema and our
return type to our front end.
Uh, and we can see that right here. See,
we have our interface code and our
return type. So, let's figure out how we
do this. Well, the first thing we do
is we ask we see if we have any code cuz
maybe the person didn't generate a
schema for whatever reason. And if they
do, we return error. But, then we start
executing.
When we execute, we build the form
builder however we want. We We take the
code and the return type, send it along
with the data.
And now when we're expecting data, we're
expecting an any type. It's any during
streaming, it's any when it's done.
There's no rendering there. And then we
build some sort of rendering engine to
render an any type object.
So, before I again show all the prompts,
I just want to we can just show really
quickly what the
what the rendering engine looks like, so
then you can have an idea of what this
is.
I have a section for rendering this, and
I just have a different ways of doing
this
along the way.
Um
execution result. If we don't have any
result or return null, we don't render
anything.
But then I just have a switch that just
says based on the tab, whether it's
table, JSON pretty, or YAML, I just
render the specific execution result.
And in this case I have like
in this case uh sorry.
Let me show you. It's very, very simple
code. JSON syntax highlighting is just a
JSON highlighter.
It's nothing fancy.
Format is YAML.
Take the JSON object, render it as YAML.
Nothing fancy.
Pretty print, make some random uh
Tailwind CSS divs.
Like I have
>> Okay, so this is your this is your like
dynamic renderer that just is the pretty
pretty printer. And you're you're
literally just recursively making little
spans with different
>> Exactly. That's all I'm doing. With some
indentation along the way.
Um
so this is kind of what we've seen most
people do. And like if you're doing
dynamic schemas, no matter what you do,
you will have to build some sort of
dynamic rendering at some point if
you're going to handle arbitrary
schemas.
So, you can download something off the
fly, you can do whatever you want, you
can make rules, but you're going to use
this type of keyword and do different
things based on what you got.
It just is the way it is. I don't really
see a shortcut around this. If other
people have different ideas, would love
to see them.
But if you have more constraint schemas,
um then you can do other things as well.
>> You can do kind of a deterministic typed
component tree where you know exactly
what happens at every layer.
>> Exactly. Um but for
>> For let's go back to actually executing
this code. So, we have this We What we
have is we have the content, so the
image that we're sending back from the
front end. We have the BAML code that
the front end told us that another LLM
told us what the schema should look
like, and the return type.
So, let's go look at what the back end
code actually does. Well, the back end
code actually does something really
simple.
We use a concept called type builder,
which is our way to do dynamic type
registration in BAML world.
>> And this is This is how you get the, you
know, BAML execution function to
actually, hey, take this dynamic schema
that was generated ahead of time, but is
not in code, and is not compiled into
the types, but take this schema and
generate something for me using that
schema.
>> Exactly.
So, then what you can do here is you can
actually just add the BAML code that was
generated from the last return type, our
last source code, you just inject it
into here, and you just say, "Hey, this
response class that I have is a dynamic
response class with a field called data,
which is going to be of the return type
the previous thing generated."
So,
in this world, let me find where this
is.
Uh
So, in this world, what this ends up
looking like is this schema gets
injected
right where it says
BAML code,
and the return type gets injected
right where it says return type. So,
image description array would go right
over here.
And then, once we do this, we get a
couple things. The first thing we get is
an exception. If for whatever reason the
source code is bad, we can just tell the
front end the source code is bad without
calling an LLM.
So, that's a nice benefit that you get
right out of free. And then, the error
message is nice, so you can feed that
error back through the generator code
and say, "This schema is bad. Don't
generate anything along the way."
And then, the next thing you can do is
if the person is streaming, you can just
execute this code, and and just pass in
the type builder along the way. So, let
me show you what the execution code
looks like cuz I think it's fascinating.
Now, the execution code is also really
simple. The execution code is a thing
that says
execute baml. So, I'm that's just my
function name. I'm going to pass in any
content I want, so it's the exact same
type signature along the way.
And then you're going to return response
type. This response type actually has no
fields defined in it at at compile time.
The only field that exists in it is the
data field, which is defined at runtime
with the return type that was provided
to us. So, now we can
>> Okay.
>> So, what ends up happening in practice
is the model doesn't actually have to
know anything. It's a very, very simple
prompt that says extract data with the
given content
you with this format, and then you just
dump the content. And because the return
type is dynamically extended
automatically,
you kind of get this for free. So, let
me show you what that ends up looking
like. And then the last thing I do,
which I think is relevant, is
when I actually handle the stream, if
you remember in in generate baml, what I
do is x.model.dump. In execute baml, all
I say is
the thing I should return to the front
end is actually my return type.data,
which is this dynamic field that I have
defined.
>> Do you have to model dump that, or is it
like there's a chance it might be a
primitive?
>> Um
I think actually the handle stream thing
does it for me, so I it works, but you
can also do it this way.
>> Okay. And so, the the reason why you
have response within dynamic inside of
it is because you have to have something
typed in the com- compiled schema to be
the return type of this function, but
then you're basically saying, "Okay, but
the body of this object can be updated."
And then when you add the baml code,
you're basically overriding that that
dynamic thing with just a single field
called data.
>> Exactly. Okay. So, what ends up
happening is let's just show what this
does. So, let's just write a test case.
So, this test case is doing exactly this
code
over here, tb.add_baml just doing the
testing world. So, these are the schemas
that I added in. So, this is part of
YAML code. And then dynamic class
response result person. So, we can name
this data just to be more consistent
with what this is.
And this is exactly the code that's
being added. And then given this test
case, what would end up happening
>> Okay, so in the test you can't
dynamically write code to call the add
types function, but you can define what
goes into the type builder as part of
your test case.
>> Exactly. So, it's basically you can just
test what would have happened if the
model did generate this thing.
So, in this case the model generated
this and this is basically what the LLM
sees. The LLM doesn't even know it's a
dynamic schema. It just thinks it is the
schema.
So, when the LLM goes and runs this, it
dumps it out and then you get this type
and you just do dot data.
>> And then when you use when you use type
builder in a test like that, um does
that override all existing types or is
that additive? Does that merge in?
>> It's additive. It It doesn't merge.
It doesn't merge for all things named
dynamic. If you add a new type like
this, it tells you like this cannot be
redefined.
>> Okay, cool. So, it is merging those in.
Cool.
>> So, it actually gives you a really nice
way to go and test stuff out.
Um so, now what you have is
boom, you get this out and then what you
return to the front end is dot data,
which is the inner part of this, which
is exactly the return type that we told
the front end we wanted. And what's nice
here is even if the LLM messes this up,
so like
um I'll do something for the sake of
doing it, but it won't really matter. Um
so, I'm going to lie to the LLM in this
prompt really fast.
Um technically I still want a data field
out, but I will not tell the LLM I want
a data field out.
So, I'll do something that's kind of
uh I'll trick it.
Cuz this is this is actually part of the
reason why it ends up working so well.
So, as you can see here, the prompt has
nothing about the data field. It's just
answering the internal schema. But even
though the model did that, you still got
the data field out.
>> Okay, so this is the baml parser doing
some magic to figure out how do we take
this data how do we take this object and
map it into the schema that we were
supposed to be
>> Which is this one. Which is the response
schema.
>> Cool.
>> A lot of times the model actually we've
seen it mess up in a lot of dynamic
schema generation especially like deeply
nested schemas and stuff.
But the fact that you can just not think
about that and just know that you're
going to get something that models the
schema that you defined even purely
dynamically.
Has we've seen increased accuracy a lot
for these dynamic situations. And what
for context like the rules of like how
complicated can dynamic schemas be?
Like honestly you can do whatever you
want. Like
if you want to do
this and like write a dumb schema that
looks like this.
You are welcome to do that.
It will do the thing for you and it'll
behave as if you randomly wrote a schema
at runtime. Uh people are like what the
heck is a schema? The schema is a
values that fit into the schema are
arrays of empty arrays. Um so
it the type type systems are beautiful
in my opinion. These are all valid uh
values of food.
Uh
>> I'm terrified to see what happens when
you run this.
>> I don't know either.
You get an empty array.
>> Okay. Okay.
Um
>> I'm going to
>> okay, we got about 5 minutes left on the
proper live stream. Do we want to bring
up Eugene to demo what he's working on
and then we can like go over a little
bit for questions?
>> I'm almost done describing this
workflow.
So once this thing is done, now that we
can get all the code out. So there's a
couple key takeaways.
Why do we not like JSON schema? Well,
because JSON schema is going to be way
more dense to go generate. I'll take the
same thing and like let's just generate
a JSON schema for this really fast.
Just to give you an idea of what I mean.
Give me a JSON schema for this. I'll
generate a JSON schema really fast.
And see what it does.
Like this is the thing the model would
have to generate.
And like we can just
look at this.
>> Uh
organizer. Like did it do it? Yes, at
333 tokens.
But it's also way less legible about
what's actually going on. This is a
fairly simplistic schema.
If I take the same thing and just like
take this,
I think we can all guess that this is
less than 333 tokens, but we can just
look at how many less.
69 tokens.
>> And it's more information-rich, right?
Like like the all of the like quotes and
parentheses just kind of add noise.
>> Exactly. And I did I did some cheating
here. And like even now, uh even when I
have extra white space here and way more
white space than I actually would have
if I were actually doing this, like I
have used two white spaces,
it doesn't even matter.
>> Third the size or a fourth the size.
>> We can just do the math, 333 / 86 /
this.
It's just like literally a fourth of the
size.
So, in general, if you're going to do
dynamic schemas, you get way more
accuracy not having to generate
something that is four times as dense
with way less information.
>> This is also kind of like I think when
they leaked the GP or not leaked, when
the GPTO SS models came out, we saw that
that their tool calling format wasn't
actually They take a JSON schema from
you over the API, but what they give to
the model is actually more like
something that's like a TypeScript-ish
syntax, which has less requirements for
like quotes and things like that cuz
it's more concise, right? And that's
what they are all on, I think probably
for the same reason.
>> Exactly. It's just you don't want
something that's dense.
Um
So, like in general, the idea is like
you want to have the model go generate
your schemas. You want to then use your
schemas for dynamic extraction of data.
You might put a human review process at
the point of generating the schemas, and
you might build a custom type form-like
thing to render your schemas in an
interesting way.
Um and you might also do a couple more
things along the way to make your life
easier as a developer.
Um, for example, you might put a cash
layer semantic cash layer that says,
"For this type of image, this is a great
schema." So, instead of generating a
schema, you might recommend an existing
schema to help the users minimize schema
clash. You might build more workflows
around merging schemas after a bunch
have been generated. And these are all
tools that you can build as an engineer
based on the use case of your actual end
users.
>> And And we actually talked about this a
lot in the episode where we talked about
like taking a resume and mapping it like
doing entity resolution and entity
mapping, which is like over time you
start to build up a set of entities or a
set of schemas, a set of types that
matter. And then when you do or doing
something expected and there's a large
drift or there's a new type of thing,
that's when you can say, "Okay, this
schema that we generated for an object
that we've seen a lot of before is very
different from all the other schemas
we've seen. Let's like put that in a
queue for human review." And you start
making more concrete. Like over time
it's just like, "Okay, yes, like we have
seen every single version of the word
Microsoft Corporation including Xbox,
including Azure, including all the All
these map to the same entity." And I
think it's the same thing of like when
we're generating schemas after off of
arbitrary images or document scans or
bank statements or whatever it is, over
time you want to start consolidating and
have be more opinionated on what it is.
And then you want to have ways to
incorporate if the standard changes, the
AI can highlight, "Okay, here's what's
different in this one." Human should
review that. Should we add that to our
whole schema or is that a sign that
there's a bug in this document or a bug
in the prompt or that the model
regressed?
>> Exactly that. Uh
Exactly that. Um, and these are
workflows. And you can build a I I It
sounds like we can't get to the React
workflow today, which is very
unfortunate. Uh, we will do that in a
second episode.
I think it was Hopefully people didn't
mind that we didn't
>> didn't get the React component working.
I knew it.
>> worried about
I'll show you the thing.
>> All right, we'll do it. We'll do it.
We'll do it on another episode.
>> Actually getting it really close to
working.
>> Okay. Cool.
>> Ed has a question real fast about any
plans that help us to convert in JSON
schema to BAML type builder?
Um we have considered this very
strongly. You should be I would be
surprised if we ship it this week. I'd
be surprised if we don't ship it by end
of year.
Uh is kind of the time frame that I
would give. We think that there probably
is a way to do JSON schema to BAML type
builder more natively through like a
native function that we support.
Um the tricky part is there's just many
many different ways that a schema can be
converted
because JSON schema is not very um
descriptive on schemas in terms of how
it does things. Um so we're thinking
about the best ways to do conversions.
And we're also thinking about adding a
top-level dynamic type. So even the
return type directly can be dynamic and
you don't need anything statically
defined.
Um any more questions from the audience
before we do any more demos? Eugene,
what do you want to show us? Do you want
to give us a quick TLDR before you show
it off?
>> Um first off, uh thanks to both you
guys. Um
but I have a BAML.
Um I think
the thing that sucks the most about BAML
is you guys hide the magic
someone putting in a prompt and then um
it just does everything correctly.
Um
where like mistakes are impossible. I
think removing process in general
um where like, you know,
often there's like a process that's good
quite good for like 90% of people.
And when you remove it, people kind of
have to go for outcomes and it's that
whole like
Jevons paradox people like talk about,
right? Where
you get to try more things and people
just work completely differently. They
try ideas they would have never tried.
Second, um
Dex, uh I really appreciate um
some of the stuff you've described for
agents, like in terms of orchestration.
I think you probably killed several like
graph theory um like mathematicians
with that stuff. Um
cuz it was intense, but it was
necessary. Um because um a lot of people
um
um there are like things that work and
don't work.
So, uh just wanted to thank you guys. Um
for the stuff I wanted to show is um how
we've been approaching some of this.
Which is inspired
>> got This is FYI, we've got 5 minutes and
I have to go to a meeting.
So, just want to give a heads-up
on timing.
>> I can hang out if you got to drop.
So, first off, um
for example, we follow we're big on
workflows. Like Bezos and his whole
like, you know, intentions don't good
intentions don't works, mechanisms do.
Uh we go harder. We'll just say like
mechanize because if you do that, you
know, worst case you'll fail, but
most things can be and you start getting
better at it and you kind of figure out
the building blocks. So, for example,
this is our spec for exposing like
an MCP
>> What what's up? Here, let me help you
out. What's the problem you're trying to
solve?
>> What we're trying to solve here is we
have our own custom product. It's kind
of cloud codish.
>> Oh.
>> And we want to let other people use it
via MCP.
So,
>> What what problem are you solving?
>> Huh? Uh people suck at using cloud code.
Uh they run out of array elements. They
also scream that cloud code is lying to
them.
>> Let's Maybe we should talk about this on
a different concept that's not about
dynamic UI, then we can bring this back
in that scenario in that case cuz it
sounds not super related to the current
topic.
>> Um
Sure. I just
um
That's fine.
Um
I just
That That's fine.
Um I just want to say that I think um
generally people can think and discuss
more than one thing and like this isn't
um
you know, a one-track course, but it's
not my thing, so that's fine.
>> Let's do it Let's do this on an episode
when we're talking about cloud code and
like general like how to write workflows
better in that world.
>> Um
Okay. It was going to be a short thing,
but that's fine. No worries.
>> Let's keep it on topic. But let's get
you on on a different episode when we
talk about cloud code.
>> Uh you said that last time, so um
anyway, it's fine.
I'm more interested in like customers
than
um that this helps customers
um
So, can I If you don't mind, I just want
to finish because this was written by my
co-founder. He doesn't write
He's not a web developer.
Um he doesn't know anything about this.
He wrote this
keywords.
>> Let's just keep going with it. Bye, Bob.
You got to drop. I'll hang out with this
on the stream.
>> Yeah. So,
this is an RFC, right?
And it's better than anything most I've
written.
But it's all spec'd.
from a YAML.
We used to do YAML, then we switched to
Zod.
Um
and um it's nicely rendered both for
humans
and machines.
Um, source tracing and the beauty of
this is that um
it lets people who you know
know how to solve problems skip the skip
the process and just get outcomes. So,
that's all I wanted to say. Sorry.
>> Okay, so this is basically for people
who are a little less technical. You've
written a system where people someone
who's less technical can build out an
ADR.
>> This guy made the Kindle. So, I think
you have to have like problem-solving
kind of mindset. But, it's more like you
don't have to become a language lawyer
in some you know react or view or
MongoDB or whatever.
>> Okay, cool. Where can people learn more
about this? Is this open source
anywhere?
>> We're trying to open source it as
quickly as possible because
um, this stuff should be open source
because if it's not inference gets
wasted.
Where Well, essentially you're having
like you're asking Einstein
hey, count my loose change.
>> Every single day over and over and over
again.
>> it hurts me. So, that's why we want to
like
um, make that stop
uh cuz there's so much better to go for.
So, so I guess sorry.
>> let's let's say you know when when this
actually um, is open source and you can
go a little bit deeper and show some of
the code. I think it would be really
cool to do a little bit of a deeper
dive. How's that sound?
>> Yeah, I'm happy to go on the code. We
have uh customers and um, whatever
if you guys anyone has feedback of what
people feel is most valuable to open
source like in what order.
Um, we're more than open to feedback and
we're like self-funded here. So, we can
do whatever we want like
>> Cool. I mean, this sounds
>> 2011.
>> This sounds like a great thing to drop
like maybe have a discussion in the
boundary ML discord about and like work
a little bit a sync and people can can
kind of like chat about and you can
maybe just describe it and we can we can
start to build momentum for for a future
conversation. That sounds really fun.
>> Yeah, thank you. And of course
couldn't have been possible without
like Baml. I think we all build kind of
on the shoulders of giants like people
who came before us. So
>> Yeah. Sorry I pointed to myself cuz I
also build on the shoulders of giants. I
was I wasn't trying to say I was the
giant and here's who the giant is.
>> I'm taller and taller.
>> I feel
like a [__] So uh
>> Yeah, we should find a I don't think
there's any photos of you and me hanging
out um and maybe we should keep it that
way.
>> I'm Roger Federer.
>> I'm going to stay for one more question.
>> Cool.
I was like, wait a minute. That's not
you I we don't that's not our DM. Our DM
has way more memes in it. Okay. Bye Bob,
you're late for a call. This was
awesome.
>> you at all.
>> Wait, really? Peace y'all. See you next
week.